ouil est Blanc Sur habin
noir IL est parti dans le
soir IL a laisse ses amis fils
poulailler qu'il n'avait jamais
quitté ill est Blanc Sur habin
noir qu'il était beau
canard IL voulait aller danser et s'
illustré Au Grand bal des oies
lustre et l'orchestre qui
passait était le meilleur du
Coin IL jouait son Grand
[Musique]
succès qui fait G Coin
Coin Je suis un mignon petit canard et
Je voudrais bien aller
danser mais personne Ne veut me faire
danseur Je suis un mignon petit canard
très triste voilà Tous les petits canards
devrait avoir le droit de
danser ilil est Blanc Sur habin
canard noir
[Musique]
c Je découvre un monde d'une seule farche
ne crains pas d'entre le
[Musique]
Dindon IL s'est assis
voiture intrigante IL vent
[Musique]
d'ercoli des
canards IL reviennent dans la
bascou et décide d'y
rester car IL tombe fou d'amour une
Jolie canne qui soutient ses vieux
jours